[Music]
everywhere all over the
place there's connective
tissue all of
this all of
it is
linked am I curious when you read the
book at what point did you see the movie
yeah around the second time I read it
three times before I approached her
about uh about writing the screenplay
and and and and directing the piece and
was around the SE the second time her
voice started to lift off the pages
beyond the the the information she was
sharing I heard the writer's voice and I
started to the images of her started to
to be conjured in my mind and the
characters started to lift off of the
pages and I wanted to see them uh living
in breathing and and portrayed by actors
and so started to think this might be a
film it's an amazing castet that you
managed to put together here and some
you've worked with before right here to
your left anenu what a wonderful
performance here and
yeah um of course you worked uh together
with in when they see us and uh and this
is your second time uh what was it like
for you though taking this on and did
you use the book as well as the
screenplay to develop this what was your
process here I would say the Brilliance
of Miss wilkerson's writing is that she
is a very personal and intimate writer
and I saw cast as a historical work
journalistic work but for me is it is as
much a memoir as anything else and so I
was able to search for those clues about
the woman in every page because her
blood uh runs through every word every
page uh every example that she uses to
to um uh bolster her argument there's
there's flesh in it for her as well she
personalizes everything so I yes I
studied the great script that I had but
my Bible also was was cast the book
that's great and of course nii you've
worked at least twice before with Ava
here also in Selma we all know another
great movie and when they see us this is
my third time yes so your third time and
this character she's moving she's funny
she's all kinds of different uh things
it's a great role and you're wonderful
in it thank you I came to the party as a
invitation to Ava uh um from Ava she
said I wrote this part with you in mind
but I had another job and she said but
I'm sad because you can't do it and I
said well what I can do friend is help
you find somebody let's think think of
somebody I sent her a full list of names
she said no to every single one and I'm
like you don't even want to read them
she was like no no no and I said okay
well you know let me see what we can do
and luckily my job at the time was
amable so I would fly from LA to
Savannah um and come right back and go
to work so it just meant a couple of
weeks for me with no off days but that's
my dear friend um and one of the most
talented people I know so she will
always have me at hello working with
anano here in those scenes you're
terrific together oh thank you well this
woman right here is so talented and for
me I knew that my my responsibility was
to provide provision for the vision to
underguard her to support her in the
film and onset you know what I mean so
that's what I wanted to show up and do
sometimes you know you just got to know
when to play your position what it is
and do it properly and that's what I
think I did for her you know and I
thought the marriage here was so
touchingly presented and it really comes
through John um even after you're gone
they've seen the movie now I don't have
to do any spoilers that's what I love
about this um you know it's it's a
wonderful Rel relationship that comes
through in a few scenes together you
actually shared a credit film credit
with Anan new before King Richard I
remember talking to you guys about that
movie uh what was this experience like
for you there's so much elegance and
Temperance to the way that Isabelle
works and that same elegance and
Temperance is in how Ava made this movie
and how Ava works and it is exactly the
same in in in in my friend Andre and and
and how she goes about it and just these
staggeringly talented women and and I
think uh like like you said it's it's
yeah it's it's it's knowing that you're
there to support knowing that you're
there to to serve and and uh I'm I'm
just it's I'm really really really
grateful that I got the opportunity you
know this started out as a Netflix
project with all that money behind it
and what happened you guys said no we're
going to make it independently we're
going to go back to our Beginnings here
because that was important why yeah
certainly when we started uh middle of
nowhere it was an independent film no
one really knew who we were were who we
were you know we were just kind of below
the radar um it was interesting as we
started to uh developed this once Ava
had a script and um it looked as if the
Netflix um mechanism wasn't going to
move forward at the pace we needed to
accomplish the film um she pitched this
idea that was you know outlandishly
brilliant um that we're going to take it
and go back
independently um Netflix was very
gracious to allow us a pathway to do
that uh but that was the easy part the
hard part then was kind of us putting
back on our independent filmmaking uh
clothes uh and getting back into the
mindset of um you know uh going out on
your own to do it uh but the beauty of
it was that there were so many things
that Ava creatively wanted to say um how
she wanted to cast the film where we
were going to shoot how we were going to
shoot what were the important stories we
were going to say um that really I can't
imagine how any other way but
independent would have given us a
pathway to this film usually independent
means independent smaller try to get as
many scenes on one set here you're going
off to Germany you're going off to India
this is almost epic like in the kind of
thing you have to do on an indie budget
here yes well we shot three countries in
37 days so the film was shot in 37 days
and you know in order to do that it's
not just about putting the money
together and trying to figure out how to
Corral that it's you know the Brilliance
of Paul Garnes and really orchestrating
all those International moves on a small
budget um but then also you know you
can't just call the studio you can't
call Labor Relations and production
insurance and all of those things it's
all just between the two of us trying to
figure that piece out and in addition to
that a lot of the Comforts that come
with those Studio films um you know we
we were uncomfortable sometimes but in
order to in order to do that you know I
I really had to have you know actors and
and in particular Andre new ell is
playing Isabelle Wilkerson right down
here we have two musical Geniuses in my
opinion yes right there Chris
Bowers who pretty much every movie I've
seen this year your name's on
it and of course greenbook on and on and
on all of his credits uh talk about your
relationship here you've worked with Ava
in many different ways you know I think
the thing that's become really clear is
um just how
much every project especially this one
is about something far bigger than uh
any of us individually you know and I
think that that ethos that Ava brings
everything she does is so inspiring from
like the very beginning of of even
talking about a project because with a
project like this I think that um from
the first time I watched it I'm already
feeling all these emotions and this this
um uh importance and this uh weight in
terms of of what I want to make sure
that I contribute to this project and
then our conversations immediately after
that are all about how can we serve this
story how can we serve these communities
how can we serve um you know uh the the
greater idea here and I think that that
type of mentality always pushes me to um
uh do my absolute best like you know
under any circumstances because it's not
about pleasing AA it's about making sure
that this uh important um piece is is uh
you know given everything that it needs
to be given tell me how you found Stan
because it's a I believe it was on
Instagram or something yes Paul Garnes
um said hey have you heard have you seen
this and he showed me a YouTube video of
a fabulous malie vocalist singing a
cover song of a Kanye a cover version of
a Kanye West song that I like ultral
light beam this this thing has gone
viral
this this this rendition that stand did
of it and I hadn't seen it so I said
who's that he's like I don't know I
don't know who is but this is a really
good song listen to his voice because he
sounded like an old black man in an
Alabama church but he looked like that I
love the whole process but also I was
scared as hell cuz I'm like oh my gosh
this there's so much on this and me
being who I am and where I come from I
want to represent me and my people and
represent my family and this song is is
my response to that it's my emotional uh
response to that and also I feel like I
have a responsibility as an artist as a
Storyteller through my music um to take
care of our people um to give power back
to the people the song is a is a
Reclamation of identity and and a
Reclamation of our culture that whole
cast system and everything about it is
you walked the walk with that and that
there were just in cameras you cameras
uh first unit second unit everybody was
equal on this can you just briefly tell
why you decided to do that yeah you know
it's almost impossible as you start the
conversation about cast as a concept to
not start identifying it in all these
other parts of your life all the
trappings of the process rely on
hierarchies uh and so one of the things
we wanted to do is specifically strip
away some of those things so like in the
camera Department uh instead instead of
the you know know a camera B camera
which inherently everybody kind of leans
on to a camera being the important one
and B B camera being less important uh
we did East and West cameras um just to
strip away just the importance of it all
the background actors are usually
relegated to their own separate scent
their separate eating all those things
um and Ava would daily go in and have
conversations with the background and
that contributed not just in making them
feel like full-fledged cast and crew
members of the project but as a group
working together it also gave us the
opportunity of adding to our story they
contributed uh in meaningful ways so
times you have those little accidents
and those are the kind of things that we
want people to know about the film
because I think I don't feel it's a It's
A Hard movie to watch I feel like it is
a an experience that we're inviting
people into and I hope people accept the
invitation thanks guys thanks so much
appreciate it thank you very
much